what we know is is education is gonna
get more online more the whole rest of
your life yeah more affordable it's
gonna have to get more comprehensive and
it's gonna have to teach in more
languages and more modalities by 20 20
to 25% of all students in school in
college English will have been their
second language doesn't even understand
it or can't master it if their second
language for a second ladies we're we're
a country of immigrants yeah and so you
know if Real Estate's kind of continue
to cost the ridiculous amounts it's kind
of cost and loans are going to be
something that saddle you were burden
you for the rest of your life we're
gonna need a lower cost more scalable
more relevant distributed more
distributed on-demand the things that
Jake is trying to do in supporting
students we're not trying to build a
curriculum we're trying to support it so
what you're seeing now is is new
companies growing up that are trying to
take advantage of corporate money
instead of instead of government money
by teaching continuing education right
right so you see online schools going to
graduate schools or masters now you're
beginning to see schools like UMass or
southern New Hampshire University or ASU
put all their undergrad online so when
you think about what is going to change
who is a student is going to change how
much they're willing to pay what that
education has to be about what should it
be the educated the cost of it of a
college degree and undergraduate degree
be today well the thing is it has to be
much lower than the ROI and it is much
lower than the ROI got right in other
words some percentage the cost of it
only equates to what the return for it
would be okay so you would pay more if
the return was going to be greater right
the challenges that return is not
greater and why because we're in one of
those massive changes right now we're
where jobs are being eliminated we're
looking at lyft and uber I see a pine on
them yeah so you take those companies
the only way for those companies to be
profitable is to do what eliminate the
driver yeah I they could raise fares $1
and I think they would lose maybe ten
percent of the customers five percent
what they lose well right now they're
competing with each other yeah that wars
got to stop right so their subsidies
have to stop right but you're talking
about antitrust stuff right so driving
will be here in ten years yeah for sure
and I don't know that I'd ever
to be in one of those myself and all
those kinds of things and there's all
sorts of problems with it but the point
is lifts losing 925 million dollars a
year yeah it's paying all it's paying 20
cents a drive to AWS yeah right and
can't make money unless the driver gets
eliminated every retail store Starbucks
they're all going to try to eliminate
yeah human help that's disastrous for
the 50% of the students that never go
beyond high school yeah or the 43% of
students that go to college that don't
get a degree so we're in one of those
stages now where we really have to be
aware of the fact that the last thing
you can do is give somebody an education
that they can't use and saddle them with
that they're never going to pay we're
destroying the future of this country
we're getting rid of 30 million there
are 30 million people working in driving
scenarios truck driving and everything
taxis everything and and retail those 30
million jobs let's just say half of them
are at risk in the you know next decade
or two yes I was ordering from a kiosk
is probably what people would rather do
well I'd rather do I will say this going
through an airport they've eliminated as
many people as they can now where you
have to buy everything and you have to
self do this and yeah I hate it but the
point is for them yeah it's a way for
them to make more money so we are
eliminating a whole strata of jobs that
used to be allowed somebody to join the
middle class yeah they were the safety
net the bridge well they were they were
there was nothing wrong with those kind
of jobs we all had them there they yeah
but some people want them for the rest
of their life too because they have
other ambitions or other needs of the
living communities where those are great
jobs there's nothing wrong with the job
but they're not going to be here yeah
and so I think the face of education is
going to be a group effort between the
student a new version of institutions
and corporations
well they've been trying to you look
look you look at Coursera EDX well those
are corporations getting involved but I
think they're doing some courses in
collaboration like audacity Udacity did
some stuff with Google I don't know how
that went but they were kind of doing
like Google's well they don't yeah look
that's that's one version of it I don't
know that I pretend that I can sit here
and tell you exactly what it's going to
click but what I do know is this it's
gonna have to be more affordable and
more available which means we're gonna
have to realize that people have
children or they have jobs or they have
both and there's no reason we can't
start bringing the education to them and
institutions that are balancing
themselves between on-premise online and
continuing education and are finding new
revenue streams to be able to make these
more affordable those are the ones
they're going to win